I was going on a few dates we were kind
of chatting a bit via WhatsApp messages
afterwards feedback that I got from some
people my response rate was too fast
what's the solution here we did this
fast
and search on the topic of
very clear responsiveness on a dating
app is a useful strategy because if
somebody messages you and you respond
within the hour you have a much greater
chance of having a long conversation and
even going on a date and so all of this
nonsense around play games match how
many hours she waited to respond and
then you do the same none of that helps
you get into a relationship with
somebody who's a good communicator
somebody who you can be yourself with
all of that is a way to just maximize a
game and you're not trying to play a
game or win a game you're trying to find
a long-term relationship